the movie begins in a small town named
urana in australia sixteen-year-old beau
is cycling back home late at night when
he hears a woman crying in a cemetery
she is naked covered in dirt and is
asking for help beau is too scared to
approach her but he hides behind a tree
and starts filming a video suddenly he
hears another noise and witnesses a man
crawling out of his grave this is
followed by several more people
appearing out of nowhere somewhere else
a police sergeant named james gets a
call from an old lady claiming that her
dog had gone out of control and killed
her sheep he goes to help her and
reluctantly puts down the aggressive dog
the police station gets a call about a
disturbance coming from the cemetery and
james being the closest one to the
location goes to check for the cause to
his surprise he finds the naked lady who
is very scared and doesn't know how she
ended up there her leg is bleeding hence
he calls for medical help a noise from
another grave makes him realize that
there are more people like her dr alicia
arrives a few minutes later and helps
the sergeant collect all the naked
people the strangers do not resist
instead they ask for help because they
are terribly confused
after gathering five people they drive
to alicia's health center only a few
minutes away however they fail to notice
an old man who is left behind bo who has
been watching the commotion from the
dark sees him walking away and follows
him out of curiosity meanwhile elisha
makes the strangers change into clean
clothes and checks their medical
condition james assumes that they are on
drugs or were performing some satanic
ritual because none of them remember
anything about themselves a woman finds
a wedding ring on her finger which
reminds her that her name is kate
another person is an italian man who
wanders away because he doesn't
understand english suddenly he remembers
a glimpse of himself running from
something the glimpse reminds him that
his name is carlo james calms carlo down
before bringing him into the house again
the sergeant then comes face to face
with kate and freezes he cannot believe
his eyes and has to touch her to find
out if she is real even then he refuses
to acknowledge her existence because she
is his wife who died two years ago dr
alicia asks him to stop joking about
such things but james couldn't be more
serious he brings out a picture of kate
which makes her remember that she was in
fact married to james she even shows him
her birthmark which confirms she is not
just a doppelganger the sergeant bursts
out into tears overwhelmed by the sudden
surprise elsewhere in the city the man
who is left behind is wandering around
while being followed by beau he finally
catches the boy and inquires what his
intentions are beau tries explaining
that he emerged from a grave but the man
rationalizes that he must be dreaming he
introduces himself as patrick and asks
to be taken to some place he can get
alcohol the kid doesn't want to tag
along anymore but patrick forces him to
back in the medical center alicia checks
the database and finds kate's medical
reports according to them she died two
years ago from breast cancer kate thinks
it is ridiculous so to get her in touch
with reality james brings her to her
grave there is a massive hole in it
which clearly means that she crawled out
of it seeing her name on the tombstone
kate panics and runs away before james
follows her his fellow policeman
sergeant vic arrives to inspect the
situation james doesn't tell him about
kate or the cemetery people not wanting
to attract more attention to her dead
wife after that he calls alicia and
tells her there are many empty graves in
the cemetery which could mean that
everyone in the medical center is
resurrected from the dead she is asked
to keep an eye on them until he finds
kate at the same time one of the
resurrecteds sees the name anna on a
book and remembers that it is her name
slowly they all start regaining their
memories a while later james finds kate
at a park they often used to visit he
apologizes for bringing her to the
cemetery and promises to take care of
her this reminds kate of how helpful her
husband was when she was on her deathbed
patrick and bo on the other hand break
into the pub patrick has been here a
long time ago hence the drastic changes
make him lose his mind he starts
breaking things before the boy offers
him a beer after that they go to a
grocery store and rob it pretending to
be a customer and a burglar they make
friends with each other in a short time
even though patrick is wildly racist and
laughs when he finds out native
americans are allowed in schools on the
way they come across a statue of patrick
and discover that he was the first mayor
of urara who died over 150 years ago
initially the old man refuses to believe
it but he soon comes to terms with his
unusual existence james brings kate back
to alicia's house and they discuss what
they should do next if the news about
their existence spreads an army of
researchers and scientists will want to
experiment on them hence they decide to
keep everything private carlo again runs
into the streets when no one is looking
he is later found by sergeant vic and
thrown into a cell the confined place
reminds him of the time he and his
brother alexandro were trapped by the
american soldiers alexandro couldn't
take the pressure so he committed the
unthinkable and while trying to alert
the soldiers carlo was shot and killed
in the present he remembers every part
of his life james arrived soon after
asking vic to go home since it is not
his shift yet vic thinks it is strange
but doesn't question him then james
brings carlo back to the house with the
others anna knows some italian and can
translate carlo's sentences for the
others it turns out that he and his
brother came from sicily when the war
began but they were trapped in a
prisoner camp in urana anna understands
what camp he is talking about because
she was also alive during the same time
alicia recalls that she has a 90 year
old patient named alexandro nico who
could be carlos's brother james offers
to drive him to his brother's house
which is just outside the city however
while crossing a bridge on the way
carlo's eyes start bleeding he screams
in pain until his body decomposes and
turns into dust james can do nothing to
help and just watches he quickly
collects the dust carlos has become and
returns to the medical center the
following morning james and kate talk
about what happened after her death by
now kate remembers almost everything
about her life she wants to go home to
sleep in her own bed but james thinks it
is better if she stays with alicia for
some time what are you hiding james he
returns home to freshen up and we see
that he has a pregnant second wife her
name is sarah and she used to be kate's
best friend in the following scene we
see another man emerging from the ground
as the others did earlier his grave
doesn't have a tombstone so his identity
is unknown alicia and james meet in the
cemetery and find out that alexandro
died last night around the same time
carlos did alicia thinks it is a
coincidence since he was very old james
is informed about a naked man running
about in a school he goes there to bring
him to safety but unlike the others this
man is aggressive james has to cuff his
hands before driving him to the medical
center meanwhile the injured girl named
kirsty has been whining in pain since
the morning it turns out that the wound
is infected and she needs to get to the
town's hospital for proper care when the
new guy is brought to the medical center
alicia acts strange she seems to know
who he is but pretends to have met him
for the first time james kirsty and
another guy named charlie who died about
a hundred years ago set off for the
hospital but when they reach the bridge
the resurrected start to get sick james
registers that it is the same place
where carlos died he immediately backs
up the car and the duo's condition
improves which means that they can only
live inside of urana if they try to
leave they will end up like carlos
elsewhere patrick and bo meet again
after spending the night apart patrick
has stolen clothes from a store but he
thinks it is okay since he is the first
mayor he has started to regain his
memories of how he looted the poor to
make more money as the mayor he also
remembers that he was killed by a native
american man outside his estate patrick
still has something important hidden in
that house that he wants to retrieve
anna and kate go out for a walk and end
up at the cemetery anna finds out that
her real name is maria and anna is her
daughter who died the same day she did
she cries on the grave asking her to
come back to life when she calms down
they decide to go to james's house they
enter through the back door and don't
take long before seeing a wedding
picture of sarah and james before kate
can brace herself a pregnant sarah
returns from the store the two quickly
run away before being caught but kate is
heartbroken a while later james finds
kate walking down the street and tries
to approach her however she refuses to
listen to him and walks towards the
bridge as a result she gets sick like
the others and he has to forcefully
bring her back to the medical center
james wants to tell vic about kate and
the others so they can ask for help from
the outside but alicia is against it
when he doesn't listen to her she brings
the group away to a secret barn without
telling him at the police station james
tells vic everything but the man thinks
he is bluffing later that night he is
driving home when he gets into an
accident the car is destroyed and his
head is injured but thankfully he comes
out of the wreckage alive weirdly enough
he doesn't go to the doctor and ends up
cleaning his wound in a gas station
bathroom he also acts very strange and
gets a sudden urge to find every
resurrected person at any cost in the
meantime maria visits her former home
which reminds her of her daughter and
husband however she is soon kicked out
by the current owners of the house in
desperation she goes to the church and
declares that she is a miracle sent by
god a worker asks her to sit down and
secretly reports to the police about the
frantic lady somewhere else beau takes
patrick around the town and they
eventually find his old estate someone
clearly lives there but they haven't
been taking care of the place patrick
starts looking for something in the
fireplace but beau is caught by a bunch
of teenagers they turn out to be
patrick's spoiled great-grandchildren
despite knowing that the kid broke in
they ask him to sit down and smoke weed
with them a while later their mother
arrives and they throw bow under the bus
to save themselves the police are called
and he is taken away while patrick
watches him from the balcony he has a
box in his hand one that he was
desperately looking for james goes to
the church and finds a crying maria he
needs her to reveal where alicia has
taken the others but she only agrees to
do so if he finds out where her husband
leon is james has already done
background checking on all the
resurrected ones and knows that leon
lives in an old age home maria meets her
husband after all these years and is
filled with happiness but leon calls her
a [ __ ]
jeez leon james discloses that the man
has dementia but maria saw that he
actually meant what he said she then
gets flashes of the past when she was
inside a car with another man touching
her leg the man's name is don smith who
james recognizes as the owner of a car
dealership he and maria go to dawn and
ask him about his relationship with her
to maria's relief dawn reveals that he
once tried to hit on her but she slapped
him across the face and walked away
after finding out the truth maria brings
james to the barn where everyone is he
finds kate alone and claims that he and
sarah only bonded because of her death
however he is not ready to forget kate
now that she is back when kate suggests
an official breakup james panics and
asks her to come with him they drive to
a house by the side of the lake that
consists of all of her belongings james
bought the house after her death because
he felt like the coffin was too tiny
overwhelmed by everything kate kisses
her husband and the two make love i hope
kate showered vic has been continuously
trying to find alicia and the group he
searches around her medical center and
even goes to interrogate sarah but to no
avail back in the barn the new guy
refuses to speak to anyone when kirsty
tries making him talk he pushes her to
the wall and hits the others as well a
while later he comes to his senses and
decides to separate from the group
elisha assures him that he will
ultimately remember who he is but the
guy simply walks away in the morning
maria goes to leon with his favorite
dish but he calls her a [ __ ] again god
damn leon the scene then goes into a
flashback maria was always faithful to
her husband but he accused her of
sleeping with dom he wouldn't listen to
her so she took the car keys and drove
away in anger but on the way she
realized anna was hiding in the back
seat the car crashed which caused the
death of both mother and daughter after
realizing that she was the cause of
anna's death maria visits the cemetery
and cries on her grave suddenly she is
approached by vic who claims that he is
here to help her
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching